Are you working on
launching an app?
That's exciting.
An important part
of app development
is understanding how people
are actually using your app.
I'm Fontaine
Foxworth and I'm here
to show you how you
can do that by adding
Google Analytics to your app.
Once you implement
Google Analytics,
you will start to
see data showing up
in your analytics account.
Often, one of the
first type of analysis
that developers
want to do is see
how many people are using it.
So you'll want to look
at your new users report.
Here, I can see that I've
gotten several dozen new users
each day.
That's great.
By looking at the
trends in new users,
you could understand if an
article on a blog or an email
may have driven new
downloads your app.
Now that people
are using your app,
it's helpful to know at what
stage users leave your app.
By using the Google Analytics
behavior flow report,
you can spot if too
many users are leaving
your app at a specific point.
It could be a particular
screen or event.
For example, you can see
here that 62% of users
are leading the app at game
over, which is probably not
surprising.
It makes you wonder
though is there
a way to decrease this number?
You can see that those
who didn't leave the app
have actually gone to the
main menu or to the tutorial.
You might consider customizing
the game-over screen
to give people the options to
go to these areas directly.
The more you drill
down into the data,
the more you could find
ways to improve your app
and keep your users happy.
It's important to use the data
to find actionable insights.
Internationalization
is a good example
of where you might
want to make changes.
Of course, it would be
nice to translate your app
into all available
language, but you
have to know which
ones to start with.
With Google Analytics,
you can look
at which countries of
the world your traffic
is concentrated in.
This particular app has
a heavy concentration
of users in Brazil.
So you might want to
consider having a localized
version in Portuguese.
Certainly, looking
at the feedback users
leave the reviews
in the app stores
can be one way to understand
how users engage with your app,
but a different type of feedback
is the actual behavior patterns
of engaged users.
Is one level hard to pass?
Is one in-app purchase
not selling well?
These questions and
more are the ones
that Google Analytics
can help you
answer so you can make decisions
based on concrete data.
This way you'll do the right
thing for users and your app.
So make sure to get started with
Google Analytics in your app
before it launches.
Check out the link
below to find out more.